.
JAKENO
WINK YOU VERY  ALSO NIOLEAGUE,
LAN, PRESIDE NS
PA HERIFENTCE
THIS WAS FOR
FE RELATED TO DRUG
D M AHE
VENTIOOHNSONNS NOW
IN FIRST INTERVIEW SINCEG THAT F
FIRST OFL,ISJOHNSON,S NKNG
JA.
NONE.
LE
FR YEARS AGO,HEE
UP THAT N'T KNOW
TH MNPRIS ME LIKE FOR
YOU FDITDEARND MEANSAD
I WEN TO TH
DIFFEN WHEN IASGHT WHO T F SLAI.
AND I WAS THERE TO S, A IN FIRS
TOIDLD ,E YOU, IS PARDON.
HE'S APARDONKEANKI STILL -- YONT
KNOWKEO ASED
WI SO IT WAS
COFF.ET YOU  I WAS RUNNING,
LITERALLY, TRYING TO MAKE ILL,
DELIVERED WHAT I
THINK A LOT O PEO FEEL WASTI SH.
YOU PRAISED PRESIDER HIS COMPA
YOUR SENTENCN GRANTINGRELEASE.
YO DID NOT
REMARKS.NAL?
OWOTIVE O
AND HIM A LAST NIGHT, I DTRIGHTO
H LITTLE BITOC M BE , ANDHEG. T
>> DO YOU WANT HIM TO BE
RE
>> WOULD T
CO WORK WITH HIM ON, PP
TO BE ABLE TONTINUWORK.
BUT JAKE, FORME,HIS IST POLICSS
PE TO REALL SYHATSIONISAID MYI I
INDE ATI.
RE ARE A DOCRTY, AND REPUBLIN
PAHO THINKT-SON TOO MANY P FOR
OFFE TON'T DESERVE THEENCES THE.
NOW, PRESIDENT OBAMA,EES TO M 1
PEOPLE WHILE IN OFFICE.
P D . THE PEOPLE
THAT HEHRSR.
IUM TT TIDENT TRUMP SHOULD BE CN
DI
THASFOR,  HOPING T WILBE
TH
RETHAT.INS S ASCH M I
WOUL HED.I  AT
OU WERE IIFDOG,
HELPING THEMHOME.
T'S
WHAT YOU'RE G. W BECAU
PRENSICAR POPULAR IN THE
HOW WITH HIM, YOURSPEAKING AT ?
WHAT DOOU
>> IEEENT
TRUMP ON A VEL.TNEAR YOU, JAKE,E
I' KIND T THE PRESIDENT H  ME A,
WHO'HIM, K  IHATNYONE ELSE ELHEY
HAVE THE RIGT THEY
FEEL.
T,Y
SE >> ALICE JO F Y BEFORE IASE
FOCUSE ISSUE
JU PASSIONR
AND S OFALSSNGRATULATIONS.
AN